what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and before we get
started spoiler warning
if you have not seen episodes one
through nine of wanda
vision but if you have or you haven't
then you just don't care the wand of
vision finale was
great we were wrong about a lot of our
theories we were right about some
but still it was action-packed super
emotional
and it did what it was supposed to do it
wrapped up the story of wanda
in west view but the post-credits scene
the second post-credit scene did set up
the next event for
wanda or now as we'll call her from here
on out the scarlet
witch and one thing that everybody has
been asking about that second
post-credit scene
and after the finale of one division is
of course is
the scarlet witch going to be a villain
this was actually a big question that
fans had going into one division is
wanda going to come out the other side
of this
as a new villain of the marvel cinematic
universe and specifically for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
well in this video i'll talk about how i
do believe she will become a villain but
not exactly how everybody thinks
because there is still a huge big bad
villain coming to the mcu
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness where i believe that the master
of the mystic arts
doctor strange and the scarlet witch
will have to team up together to
defeat this enemy so let's dive into it
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on
any of the latest marvel news and videos
the inherent question of
is wanda or the scarlet witch good or
bad has been asked since before
one division even came out when we knew
that she was going to create this fake
reality
but as the show went on and she held
people hostage and her herself
even questioned if she was indeed the
villain this question was asked more and
more is she good or bad well it's your
classic she's a good person who did some
bad things
originally done by accident her chaos
magic simply exploded and created what
she wanted
her perfect life with her perfect family
however ultimately she would give up her
family to save everybody
but wanda can now change reality and
judging by how in control of her chaos
magic she was by the end of one division
not to mention the post-credits scene it
seems like she knows exactly how to make
her reality
whatever she wants it and this is now a
pretty big issue because
of the post credit scene where she found
her children how do we know that this is
an issue
because of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness it picks up
right where one division leaves off and
of course where spider-man nowhere home
leaves off which is rumored to be a
multiverse movie as well
the hex that the scarlet witch cast
already caused some people like
monica to have their dna altered what
more effects could come
from the scarlet witch tampering with
realities in order to find her kids
only chaos could really happen when
wanda sets out to do this
and this is actually a way bigger threat
than before because you see in one
division
wanda knew that her kids and vision were
fake and she knew that she was
controlling everything even if she
didn't remember doing it she knew that
she was in control
and she knew that people were suffering
by her hand yet she continued to want to
live in her perfect reality with her
kids
and vision even though real people were
hurting and her family was fake
but now wanda is in the real world and
in the post-credits scene she heard the
voices of her kids implying that they
are
alive somewhere there's now a chance
that her children are real
and a chance that she could actually
have a real family
wanda captured a whole town to have her
fake family what will she do
when she has a chance to have a real one
especially now that she's in control of
her chaos magic
and has the dark hole to learn from and
the darkhold isn't exactly a good
teaching book as agatha called it it's
the book of the damned and it was
written and forged by the evil elder god
c'thon
but more on that in just a bit one thing
that one division never really explained
in any detail whatsoever
is the nexus commercial well really they
didn't explain any of the commercials in
any details but specifically the nexus
commercial was never explained but the
nexus commercial said it was for
a pill that helps anchor you back to
your own reality
or the reality of your choosing you see
in the marvel universe
every reality has a nexus being and
these beings are essentially responsible
for
holding up their reality keeping it
together and sometimes they alter it
slightly and alter the timeline for the
good of the reality but for the most
part they're supposed to make sure that
it stays together
now of course wanda doesn't really know
that she is a nexus being she's just now
learning about her chaos magic and the
fact that she is indeed the scarlet
witch but there's no doubt that her
being a nexus being will be explored in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness because as he's always been
saying his job is to protect the reality
and
this is another reason why wanda is
going to be a bad guy in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness because
she's going to be trying to do
something that doctor strange is not
going to be okay with and i believe that
this is going to be her
tearing through different realities in
order to find her kids
you see before one division wanda didn't
really know anything about
witches agatha told her that she has
been a witch since she was born and
wanda said no she argued with her and
i'm still not exactly convinced that
wanda is indeed a true witch but
regardless she is learning
witchcraft from the darkhold and as i
said before the darkhold is not
a good book it's an evil book so
everything that is being taught
inside the book is not for good it's for
bad and
wanda is now learning everything inside
of this book so she's essentially
learning
evil hexes hexes that we can assume that
she is going to use to find her kids
because that's what it looked like in
the post-credits scene
it actually looked like she was looking
in different realities
universes realms whatever you want to
call it for her children
as she was hovering over the bed reading
her book we could see a bunch of
different circles surrounding her
now you can also see these circles in
the dark hold when agave harkness is
opening it up to talk about what it says
about the scarlet witch they're on the
left page these certainly do look like
they could be different realities
so there's a very good chance that this
book is teaching
wanda how to actually go to different
ones the only
problem with this is is that wanda is a
nexus
being she is actually responsible for
maintaining the reality so when you have
somebody responsible for keeping the
reality together
go off the deep end and start breaking
realities it's never good
so yes wanda is indeed going to be a
villain originally but she's not going
to be the next
big bad and this could be a relief for
some people i know some people wanted to
see wanda be a big bad villain but a lot
of people don't want her to be one she's
been through a lot and doesn't deserve
to be a villain she just wants her
family
and after doctor strange kind of talks
to her and whips her into shape a little
bit
she'll be all right but unfortunately
she'll have released the next
big bad of the marvel cinematic universe
and this is going to be either the evil
elder god
c'thun nightmare or mephisto one of
these beings or a combination of the
three of them
will eventually show up and you have to
take into account that nightmare was
originally going to be the first doctor
strange villain in the first film but
they decided to go with nightmare for
the second film which wanda is going to
be a part of but the interesting thing
about all of these villains is that they
are actually trapped in different
dimensions different realities
not in the main one that wanda is
responsible for holding together
however they are all trying to get back
to the main reality you see in the
comics c'thun
actually created the darkhold and he is
the one responsible for giving wanda his
chaos magic
because he is also the creator of chaos
magic as well and he did both of these
things create the darkhold
and give wanda chaos magic so he could
one day eventually return
to this main reality so if you have a
big bad such as one of these three
who are trying to get back to the earth
reality from where they once came from
now is going to be a pretty good time
because the nexus being responsible for
holding the reality together
is actually going to be tearing it apart
leaving a perfect opportunity for the
villain to make his return
i believe this will happen because of
what agatha said in the one division
finale
she said sort of the same thing two
different times she said
you have no idea what you've done and
you have no idea what you've unleashed
she even went as far as to say
you're going to need me but she'll have
doctor strange to help her fortunately
in multiverse of madness but agatha is
referring to one of these ancient beings
being released wanda essentially
released the scarlet witch
and with that really released her chaos
magic which could open a gateway for
c'thun to return
after all that was his plan in the
comics to possess somebody like wanda as
a vessel for his way to return so again
wanda might be an unintentional villain
luckily this is kind of dr strange's
specialty
preventing demons from coming into the
reality and taking over it and
destroying it is kind of what he does
and this is exactly why the two connect
one is because the multiverse is going
to be thrown into madness
wand is going to go looking for her kids
and she's going to tear apart the
reality
and the second is while she's doing this
she's actually opened up the universe
for the eventual return
of this big bad so to end it with the
inherent question is wanda good or bad
she's good she's just going to stop at
nothing to get her real family back
however unfortunately as she tries to do
that she has
unleashed an evil big bad and will
shatter the multiverse in the process
which doctor strange is going to have to
help
with both and that's when we're going to
see doctor strange and the scarlet witch
team up to face on the next big bad
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness has already began filming so
more on them soon so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news be sure to let me know what you
think about this video in the comments
down below
don't forget to give it a like and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof